we've done a few videos on passwords
cracking passwords choosing good
passwords and I've had had a few
requests both by email and you know
Twitter and on in the comments about a
choosing a password mechanism called
dice where so I thought we'd look at
this and think what's the pros and cons
of this of this quite interesting system
for choosing passwords so here's my nice
unbiased casino dice that I got just for
this occasion I was quite excited
apparently this fish dice is not biased
towards rolling a six which actually
would just mean my performance in games
goes down when we spoke about passwords
last time my hypothetical password
mechanism was something like four random
words with a bit of symbolic symbols
added in maybe randomly in the middle of
a word now I chose that because I felt
it was a a nice compromise between
hackers type something in but it's
really really long or and having
something that's not too hard to
remember but also quite hard to break
now dollar swears in some sense quite
similar to this scheme but it's perhaps
more mathematically defined exactly how
hard it is to break which is why people
like it because I think the question
comes down to in my scheme if I pick
four random words how random are Bo's
worse truly if an attacker wanted to
brute forth my password then and they
know for example that I'm using for
words appended together then what
they're going to want to do is try and
work out the list of all the words I
might have used now I try and throw them
off a bit by using slightly odd words
but I'm a bit weird but for the majority
people let's imagine that everyone in
the country where everyone in the world
is using this password scheme lots of
people are going to pick really easy
words you know back to the correct horse
battery staple thing xkcd alluded to
this and we'll talk about that in a
minute but didn't necessarily answer
every question but it did get a good
message across the entropy or the number
of possible words that you've chosen is
gonna differ from person to person right
if one of my words I pick is database is
that because I've picked that right out
at random or is it because it says
database is on this book up here and I
accidentally saw it in the corner of my
eye
don't panted a bit with no books on it
yeah I'm just looking at your collection
of cubes all solved that's high well so
what dice where does the website was
established in 1995 by a guy called
Weinhold from the United States what it
is is a way of using dice to ensure that
the words you're picking are actually
random rather than just what you think
is random and that way we have a very
nicely defined should we say
mathematical difficulty for group
forcing that password so this is the
dice where lists but I guess it's a kind
of compromise between the number of dice
you just have to roll incessantly to
come up with passwords and being fairly
quick but there are 7776
words on this which is all the different
combinations of five dice rolls right
now so that's why I've got my nice
unbiased dice we don't wanna be
accidentally biasing me towards the end
of this document for example so as an
example we roll the dice it's a five
each of these has five numbers from one
to six in front of the word which tells
you which words are going to pick so
these are the fours I'm on to the five
says there's the start of the fives
there then roll the dice again it's a
six so I'm now on to the five sixes
which is here and then again five six
four five one five six four five one is
the word tapir whereas in the animal
with the snout so that's the first word
of my password so let me write that down
this could take a little while this is
where you need to use all of your video
editing skills tapir right let's do this
again okay 1 3 2 1 3 if you've done this
a lot of times maybe it'd be faster 1 3
2 1 3 there we are back up nice 5 1 3 3
what is it 1 5 1 3 3 1 how many times
have you got to do this a good question
it was Rand interesting a the our South
African currency yeah and also short for
random which is what we're doing now 5 2
4 6 2 RW interesting read/write yeah
so not all of these are full words
that's one of the thing that's quite
about this 3 6 having been in 2 3
exciting three six four two two three
six four two two they're guaranteed to
be unbiased I think but then I got them
cheaply off the internet so I don't
actually know okay so let's let's stop
let's stop there I've done I've got five
words right now is this pasta really
good well the first thing to notice but
what you don't want to do when you're
picking a password is record it on video
and show it on the internet so I
probably won't put this is my actual
password but there will be a few people
that try normal s we've altered eyes
five times per word we find the word and
then we put spaces in between it and
that's our past phrase right so that is
literally our password then for whatever
purpose we want why is this better than
what I was doing well it's different
mostly there's a few questions we've got
right the first is but is this a
reasonable password in terms of strength
also how practical is it to type in
right it took a little while to generate
but if you're doing it a couple of times
for the front end of a password manager
maybe that's not such a big deal one
thing that's worth noting is but this
isn't all the words in the English
language this is this is a carefully
chosen 7700 words but a knife is short
so most of the words are fewer than five
characters there's a few really short
ones the idea being that even if you've
got a five word or six word passphrase
it's never going to get that long you
should get quite quickly typing it in
but the real benefit of this system is
that these are actually random as
opposed to what I've perceived to be
random because I thought of a word in my
head which might have been a word that I
happen to see on the side of a bus this
morning in the previous videos we talked
about brute forcing about not you
knowing what any of the characters were
and how we make it easier for the
attacker by using a dictionary of known
words yeah so this is literally
providing dictionary right yeah that's
the drawback in some sense and the
strength so we know exactly what words
could appear in my passphrase but even
so we still can't break it because I've
used too many of them so in some
password schemes like ones where I pick
words at random from a dictionary in my
own brain I'm working under the
assumption but that's secure because no
else knows how it works no one can
reverse-engineer that process that might
be true it might not be true it depends
how well you know me this the process is
extremely open everyone knows what the
password list was everyone knows what my
password is going to be like but they
still can't break it because it's 2 to
the 64 operations which is too much what
we don't want is security through
obscurity right if I use it if I only
use a 500 word dictionary right that's
fine as long as I keep that dictionary
secret if I doesn't seem like a very
good idea because then that dictionary
might accidentally come out and then it
would be incredibly easy to break my
password so what is the strength of his
password well each of these words has
come from 7776 right so we can assume
that the attacker knows but I'm using
this password scheme so they know my
password is five words separated by
spaces which adds nothing because they
know what the spaces are out of a
possible 7776 so the strength of this
password is actually 7 7 7 6 to the 5 so
another way of looking at it isn't how
many bits of entropy does this password
have but a lot of the time that's how we
view passwords each of these words is 12
point 9 bits so 12 point 9 times by 5
words is 64 point 5 bits which is pretty
good actually that means that on average
an attacker is going to have to do about
2 - 63 - - just under 64 operations to
guess your password in brute-force
that's quite a lot of operations
particularly given they're going to have
to perform some hash to do this the nice
thing about this password scheme is we
know exactly how secure it is right as
opposed to we're guessing that the words
aren't just words I know and someone can
social engineer those words and also if
we want it to be more secure we can just
add another word or another word as
computational power goes up we just add
more words and we can probably remember
a few words or if they get really long
write them down and put it in our wallet
don't lose it I'm guessing as well you
could potentially vary the whole spaces
thing right yeah so the state the spaces
thing is not hugely important the reason
it's there is because sometimes you
might accidentally join two words
together and
actually be a different word on here in
which case your search has gone down to
four words right so if you're being
careful that these are all actually
different words and they don't
concatenate to make another word you
don't need the spaces or you could use a
different character you could also do
what I did and use fewer words and put a
random character in right now on the
website he has plenty of ways of loading
dice and also choosing random characters
because again when I pick a symbol it's
often you know a star or an ampersand or
an underscore those aren't all the
characters of it exist so it's a really
interesting twist on picking passwords
this came about you know a few years ago
now where maybe a fork out a four word
password was reasonable now in some
sense you can't imagine but a seven or
eight or nine word passwords are back
feasible for the majority of users that
there has to be some usability
considerations but on the other hand
finds not too bad or as I say four but
they make an unexpected alteration like
an adding of a random symbol at a random
position not between the words and that
weight significantly increase the amount
of time it would take to break you can
get too carried away like with passive
security I have and so half a time I
can't login because I get my password
wrong and so I've been but the thing you
also you have to remember is that this
is way beyond a normal brute-force
attack by someone who's just happens to
have found your password hash on
pastebin right this is when we when
we're talking about five or six word
passwords where we're talking about
nation state level and you've got to
really wonder whether they really care
about your individual password you might
still want to secure it against them
anyway that's that's for you to decide
but they may just visit you instead
we'll put a link to the website in the
description as well so you can have a
look through he's considered almost
every possible angle for this so when do
you add symbols how many words is enough
for the level of security you want it's
a really good interesting look into
password security so I recommend you
have a look